spécialiste du transport de personnes à
mobilité réduite il se retrouve à pied
les salariés de Lucky Star contestent
les inégalités salariales au sein de
l'entreprise et regrette la remise en
cause de leur statut de non remisant en
clair ces employés pouvaient jusqu'à
présent rentrer à leur domicile avec
leur véhicule professionnel en grève
depuis hier soir ce mouvement a des
répercussions sur les services proposés
par l'entreprise on a notre charge des
personnes à mobilité réduite on a
conscience de la gêne qu'on occasionne
ça a été l'extrême limite le fait de
déclencher une grève ça a été pour nous
vraiment une situation on va dire
extrêmement extrêmement difficile
maintenant je pense que à la direction
de prendre tes responsabilités certains
usagers se plaignent de récents
dysfonctionnements il y a quelques
semaines cette cliente n'a pas été
ramenée à son domicile par son chauffeur
après son activité ce service lui coûte
pourtant près de 90 euros par mois
chez vous personne mais là il y avait
comment on dit assistant en perçant en
danger qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
fasse de Versailles en Montigny j'y vais
en voie en fauteuil
la grève suivie par plus de 50% des
employés devraient se prolonger pour une
durée illimitée la direction joint de
par téléphone affirme avoir fait 4
propositions dont la mise en place d'un
calendrier annuel de négociation
salariale